it's back to school and time to get back
to clean and joining me is ben mckee
general manager of xero res las vegas
who is sponsoring this segment ben
good to have you back in studio first of
all i love the the carpet um segments
that we do with you guys because it's
amazing what zerorez is capable of but
first of all let's talk about it's a
perfect time to refresh we start clean
how do you know if your carpet is ready
for a cleaning no i always say if your
carpet looks dirty it's dirty it's time
to get it clean what have you got
traffic areas spots stains
gives you a resin call it's time to get
your carpets cleaned and i'd recommend
getting your carpets clean every 6 to 12
months that actually comes from the
carpet and rug institute of their
recommendation
and if you've got pets or children you
may want to increase that frequency well
let's talk about the zero res difference
because i really do think it makes a
huge difference you don't use those
harsh chemicals and detergents when you
clean you use zero res water tell us
about that we do we call it z water and
people are always like what's this crazy
magic water that y'all use but it's
alkaline water and we have a patented
cleaning system that allows us to clean
without soaps detergents and harsh
chemicals like you were saying
and it eliminates the crunchy sticky
nasty carpets that are usually left
behind with traditional cleaning methods
and one thing i've noticed when you do
clean with your
your water it actually dries a lot
faster it does we typically get about a
four to five hour dry time
when we clean the carpets at your home
or at your business let's show the zero
res difference here this carpet is just
nasty oh what were you doing to this
were you walking all around and driving
on it or what what's going on here okay
look at the difference when you take
just one swipe
you can already see
how it changes that's one swipe and you
go over it more than once oh yeah well i
mean we'll clean it to make it look as
good as possible but it's amazing that
with this cleaning process there's no
soaps there's no harsh chemicals this is
strictly the power of water
and that's good for
yourself your family the pets
let's talk about some of the pet stains
right now it's the dog days of summer
and that could be like literally
it's hot outside and you know our pets
we love our fur babies but they can
cause some catastrophic messes in our
house with hair pet stains zero res
we've got an arsenal of products to
safely and effectively eliminate those
issues for you
and your family and it's not just your
carpets what else do you guys take care
of we can clean just about anything you
live on your carpets upholstery tile and
grout we even clean businesses our
cleaning process is strong enough even
for casinos hotels or office buildings
i've even tried to convince zero reds to
to clean my laundry you guys would do
that one though but we haven't gotten
there yet
no this is a phenomenal and you can get
your home back to clean too we have a
special offer back to school special and
when viewers call you can still enjoy a
vegas staycation with two free passes
from cowabunga bay las vegas's number
one water park i love that you guys give
those away when you come in so give
zerorez a call at
xerorez las 702-840-3333 dot com that
great offer again they're back to school
back to clean special three rooms of
carpet clean for only 99 plus you get
two free passes to cowabunga bay minimum
supply las vegas now we'll be right back